Welcome to level two.
This level will go super fast if nothing
goes wrong and even if you have to do
some troubleshooting, in under an hour
you should have a libgdx game up and
running on both your desktop and
your android phone or tablet.
We'll learn a little bit about the kind
of complex structure of a libgdx
application.
Learning where to find the code that
is shared between all the back ends.
And where to find the code that
is specific to each back end.
We'll also learn a bit about the tool
that handles all of the compiling of
code and processing of resources
that goes into a libgdx build.
Then we'll build the android and
dust out versions of the app and
we'll call it a day.
You'll be encountering a whole ton of
new tools and programs in this level.
And it might seem a bit
like tool overload.
While you could go ahead and read
a book on every new tool you encounter,
it'd be really hard to get
anything done that way.
So the best way to learn a tool
is really just to start using it.
And for my part, I'll do my best
to contextualize every new tool we
encounter so
that they don't seem so mysterious.